it's all but impossible to tell a truly
original story after over a century of
cinema it's safe to say that virtually
every possible premise has already been
covered but some movies don't even
attempt to be even a little original
stealing their plots almost wholesale
from films that came before
here are some classic movies that are
all but carbon copies of other films
alien no one's claiming alien was the
first movie ever about evil aliens but
it's amazing just how much it has in
common with the 1958 b-movie it the
terror from beyond space both movies
have the exact same setup a ship lands
on an alien planet and is invaded by a
hungry violent monster that hides in an
air shaft
[Music]
both movies also end with the alien
getting defeated by the vacuum of space
not that the people behind alien will
admit to the inspiration producer David
Guyler denied his film was a ripoff only
saying that aliens hook of the creature
hunting inside the ship was pretty much
a classic premise with science fiction
writers like the gunfight in the Western
at the same time he threw writer Dan
O'Bannon under the bus scene his
original draft was terrible at nothing
but a ripoff of 1950s sci-fi as Guyler
put it it wouldn't surprise me at all to
learn that Dan O'Bannon stole the idea
Star Wars it's no secret that George
Lucas didn't create Star Wars out of
thin air as the BBC reports Star Wars
almost certainly wouldn't have existed
without Akira Kurosawa's 1958 samurai
epic the hidden fortress even Lucas
himself admits as much kind of the one
thing I really struck me about hidden
fortress and I was really intrigued by
was the fact that the story was told
from the two lowest characters for
fortress that was too argumentative
peasants while in Star Wars it was the
droids c-3po and r2d2 even the post
Lucas Star Wars Oh a hand to fortress
Rey's staff looks a lot like the ones
used by fortresses generals that however
seems more like a tribute than
suspiciously heavy lifting a fistful of
dollars George Lucas isn't the only
filmmaker to borrow from Akira Kurosawa
but he can thank his lucky stars that he
wasn't one of the people Kurosawa sued
for theft Sergio Leone director of A
Fistful of Dollars wasn't quite so
fortunate as explained by LA Weekly the
spaghetti western was almost a total
remake of Kurosawa's 1961 samurai
classic Yojimbo both featured the exact
same story a quiet loner comes to a
small town where two gangs are fighting
for control he casts himself as a double
agent working for both sides and then he
rides off with a fabulous cash reward
both also took the same approach to the
western genre making it gritty and dark
turning the good guys into slightly
nicer bad guys and utilizing multiple
close-ups of the characters faces to up
the intensity the quiet loner goes
without a name in both - so you can see
why Kurosawa saw red when he saw dollars
saying it is a very fine film but it is
my film
according to site B Magazine he sued
Leone for plagiarism and Leone
a pain Kurosawa 15 percent of his films
royalties plus a cool $100,000 The
Hunger Games The Hunger Games is a
legitimate cultural phenomenon but it
only got that way by lifting its central
premise from another film as The New
Yorker points out Hunger Games is based
on the same premise as the 2000 Japanese
movie battle royale both feature
dystopian society that requires children
to battle each other they're taken to a
special arena given weapons and forced
to fight until only one person is left
plenty of people have pointed out the
similarities between the two films and
the books they were based on but for her
part Hunger Games author Suzanne Collins
claims that she didn't rip off anyone
when asked about battle royale in a New
York Times article Collins replied I had
never heard of that book or that author
until my book was turned in at that
point it was mentioned to me and I asked
my editor if I should read it he said no
I don't want that world in your head
just continue with what you're doing if
anything the movie that the Hunger Games
borrowed from the most was Spartacus in
the same interview Collins claimed I was
also heavily influenced by the
historical figure Spartacus Katniss
follows the same art from slave to
gladiator to rebel to face of a war cars
Pixar movies are famous for their
quality even their weaker offerings like
cars are fun and watchable but there's a
major flaw with cars and for once it's
not Larry the Cable Guy see cars is the
story of an arrogant racecar who crashes
in a small town is sentenced to
community service and eventually has a
change of heart and decides to live
there permanently just passin through
actually I thought stop and stay a while
as the Guardian mentions this is almost
exactly the story of DOC Hollywood a
1991 movie where Michael J Fox plays an
arrogant city doctor who crashes in a
small town is sentenced to community
service and eventually has a change of
heart and decides to live there
permanently come back to Los Angeles
I don't want my Sanja you the makers of
doc never bothered to sue Pixar which
would have been totally unnecessary
anyway the humiliation of Cars 2 was
punishment enough Disturbia 2007's
disturbia is about a kid stuck in his
room who passes the time by watching his
neighbors from afar he begins to suspect
one is a murderer
and it turns out he's right meanwhile
1954 s rear window is about a grown man
stuck in his room who passes the time by
watching his neighbors from afar he
begins to suspect one as a murderer and
it turns out he's right it turns out
those similarities were enough to bring
a law suit into the picture
in 2008 the trust that owns the rights
to the 1942 short story rear window sued
the makers of disturbia claiming they
remade the story without clearing it
whereas alfred hitchcock had received
permission to make his movie version
disturbia had not despite clearly making
almost the exact same movie and yet the
court disagreed ruling that disturbia
was an original film as the presiding
judge explained the setting and mood of
the short story are static intense
whereas the setting and mood of
disturbia are more dynamic and peppered
with humour and teen romance
sounds like DreamWorks got the last
laugh
lockout usually when a filmmaker steals
from another movie they pick something
relatively obscure so the theft isn't
immediately obvious
Luke Poisson went the opposite route
when filming 2012's lockout targeting
the 1981 classic Escape from New York an
escape Kurt Russell plays a convict who
enters a post-apocalyptic New York City
now a giant prison controlled by the
inmates to rescue the president in
lockout Guy Pearce plays a convict who
travels to a space station now a giant
prison controlled by the inmates to free
the president's daughter about my father
oh yeah yeah I made that other day do
you have a message for me yes you are
adopted you can see why escapes director
John Carpenter decided to sue Busan for
2.4 million dollars plagiarism can be a
mighty expensive hobby as the Guardian
reports the judge initially awarded
carpenter eighty five thousand euros the
son appealed and the appeals court
increased the ruling to four hundred
fifty thousand euros they decided Visan
stole tons of details from carpenter
writing in their judgment the heroes
both got into the prison by flying in a
glider space shuttle had to confront
inmates led by a chief with a strange
right arm found hugely important
briefcases and meet a former sidekick
who then dies and at the end both heroes
keep secret documents recovered during
their mission Reservoir Dogs some rip
offs are just bad copies of the movie
they stole from but others actually
improve on the original best example
Quentin Tarantino's 1992 breakthrough
Reservoir Dogs which according to
critics swipes several scenes from Ringo
lambs 1987 film city on fire Tarantino
didn't steal city note-for-note but
rather copied the basic plot plus
several scenes both films are about
criminals blowing a major heist and one
of them winds up being an undercover cop
as the Baltimore Sun pointed out
Tarantino took several scenes including
the famous Mexican standoff where two
criminals and the officer form a
triangle and point guns at each other
other scenes include a man with two guns
shooting cops through a windshield men
in black suits walking through a city
and the robber learning the undercover
cops identity what's more Tarantino
admits this lifting outright selling the
Sun Cities a really cool movie it
influenced me a lot I got some stuff
from it
least he's honest as indieWIRE points
out the rest of Reservoir Dogs is pure
Tarantino visually the two are nothing
alike and both take extremely different
cultural tones The Lion King initially
the Lion King seemed as original as
anything could hope to be but as it
turns out Disney has been accused of
swiping a lot of it from a Japanese
cartoon called Kimba the White Lion as
the Los Angeles Times reported Lion King
shares almost too much with Kimba to be
a coincidence both include supporting
characters like a wise old baboon and
crazy hyenas oh and - goofy sidekicks
the film's main plots differ enough but
certain scenes appear in both remember
when Mufasa
ghost appears in the clouds to give
Simba life advice Kimba did that too
we're supposed to help each other
[Music]
just as it was for you also at one point
in Kimba and evil lion named claw
assumes the throne when kimba's away
claw also has a scar around his eye I
have come home to take over my father's
jungle you got a problem sound familiar
then there are the opening scenes in
both when Simba and Kimba both stand on
rocks over scene their future kingdoms
the makers of Kimba have declined to
take action and instead have praised
Disney saying our company's general
opinion is the Lion King is a totally
different piece from Kimba and is an
original work completed by Disney's long
lasting excellent production technique
the island Michael Bay's 2005 sci-fi
action thriller the island attracted the
wrong kind of attention namely from the
people behind 1979's parts the colones
horror who sued him for stealing their
movie both movies concerned a secret
colony of human clones secretly
harvested four body parts
what's more both have hero clones
discovering what's happening and
invading Southern California to shut
down the program and expose the people
behind it
neither lit the box-office on fire but
clonise had the excuse of being an indie
flick bad enough to get roasted on
Mystery Science Theater 3000 the island
meanwhile was a 120 million dollar
michael bay epic one person who did see
it however was robert v sin producer of
colones he noted the islands trailer
made it seem an awful lot like his movie
so he went to check it out and found
over 90 cases of overlap which he
detailed in a lawsuit as he told variety
it's beyond the premise it's specific
characterizations it's specific lines
shot compositions and sequencing suing
was apparently the right idea as base
settled out of court reportedly for
seven figures though compared to the
eight figures the island lost at the box
office
sevens not so bad thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]